- [narrator] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learned? Visit
our website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
- We are the paradoxical ape, bipedal,
naked, large-brained, long the master of
fire, tools, and language, but still
trying to understand ourselves. Aware that
death is inevitable, yet filled with
optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand down
knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here, an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- [Potts] There are many fundamental
problems in the study
of human evolution, an immense
array of really intriguing questions,
in part because the
evolutionary journey has
involved an astonishing transformation.
One way of looking at this transformation
is through a pairing of slides. I thought
I'd start with the raciest one first but
also the most endangering in some ways.
But it poses, this pairing of slides I'm
gonna show you, poses a question, and
it's, how is it that our ancestry
included, and in imagined way
in this reconstruction, dilemmas
and survival challenges, such as this? And
then in our species that we can present
ourselves with a survival challenge like
this. How is that kind of transformation
even possible? Ed White's space walk, the
first human to take a walk in space, how
is it, if, in fact, evolutionary process
tethered our species through a change over
time, tethered our species to inhuman
possibilities and mentality and society to
a particular ancestral habitat and to
particular conditions of life? How can
that transformation have taken place?
Another pairing of slides that I think
captures this is ...can be expressed in
this way. The oldest known stone tool
tradition, the old one dating back to
about 2.6 million years ago, and the
question that's posed here is how is our
evolutionary ...how is it that our
evolutionary journey and technology go
from something like this to something like
this?. And as you can read there, this is
space debris that is encircling the Earth.
Right there, the entire planet has become
an archaeological sight. And so in many
different ways, our species resides on a
human altered planet. Well, in seeking to
understand transformation such as this, we
run right up against the fundamental
scientific challenge of seeing ourselves
as a phenomenon of nature. And I think
that sadly, the folkways in which we see
our species often sees in the science homo
sapiens almost as an aberration of nature,
and the dichotomies, the traditional
dichotomies, line up in a series of false
oppositions. Human versus nature. Cultural
versus natural. Learning versus instance.
Even human versus animal. And it's
especially that ladder dichotomy that
highlights the fosted division that occurs
in this particular perspective. Now human
evolution is the period
I've been looking at so far in this first
several talks, namely the past six or
seven million years of Earth's history,
where the baseline adaptations and the
initial possibilities of our species
emerged in ancestors who are no longer
around. And so one way to pursue the
question in how the accumulation of
adaptations occurred over time is to
examine the environmental context of that
entire time period. And so data like this,
which have been shown in the previous two
talks, and also is shown on the front of
your programs, is the oxygen isotope curve
showing changes and the trends and
fluctuation and ocean temperature and
global ice volume. It's an iconic diagram
of paleo-climatology, and it shows up the
past six million years corresponding with
the period of human evolutionary history
have been one of the most dramatic periods
of climate oscillation of the Cenozoic era
of the past 65 million years. As Peter
deMenocal showed in his talk,
paleo-climate records express at least two
signals, the overall trend as well as the
variability. And up to about, I would say,
20 years ago, nearly every student in the
study of human evolution considered the
variability as simply noise in the
all-important trend toward a cooler and
dryer Earth. It was the direction of
change, the direction of change, the onset
of grassland dominated savannas, and in
East Africa or Africa in general, and of
Ice Age conditions in higher latitudes,
that was thought to be the signal, the
signal that elicited the emergence of
uniquely human adaptations. Yet all of the
environmental records also show periods of
strong instability of amplitude variations
in, as they were switches between arid and
moist and between cool and warm. Now among
many factors that have an influence on
Earth's climate system, Earth's orbital
dynamics certainly are one of them as
expressed in this figure. We live on a
spinning planet, who's axis of rotation is
tilted, and therefore, there are
variations, fluctuations in the amount of
solar radiation that hits the Earth at
different times of the year and different
places on Earth. And so we see these three
variables represented here of
eccentricity, the shape of the Earth's
orbit around the sun, the tilt of the
Earth's axis also varies eccentricity, the
shape of the Earth's orbit, the first
factor, goes from a more circular orbit to
a more oval or elliptical orbit, the tilt
of the Earth's axis of rotation varies,
and also there is this wobble in the
Earth's axis of rotation that relates to a
precision. Well, when you look at African
climate, and really climate all over the
globe, but African climate is strongly
influenced by variation in solar
insulation. And looking at two major, two
of those variables, it's the interaction
of orbital precision, which have cycles of
19,000 and 23,000 years approximately, an
eccentricity the shape's of the Earth's
orbit around the sun,
which has periodicities
of about 100,000 years and
about 413,000 years.
You put those four wavy lines together,
four basically sine curves together, and
the interaction of them shows that there
is this interacting ...there are these
alternating phases of high and low climate
variability in tropical Africa. Peter
deMenocal has been instrumental in helping
me to understand this as we got together
in a project a number of years ago. And so
what we've been able to do, and this is
going to come out in the publication soon,
is that we've been able to label according
to very specific intervals of changes
between the high climate variability times
and the low climate variability times of
labeling back through time, back over the
last five million years we've been able to
do this. The highs and the low. The times
of strong instability in East African
climate, where the amplitude of dry and
wet were exacerbated or magnified versus
times of greater stability, the low
periods. And what we've been able to show
is that the times of record that Peter has
studied, for example, the dust records as
well as the wet-dry cycles that are
recorded in the Mediterranean relating to
eastern and northeast African climate,
support this alternation and this pattern
of division between high and low climate
variability. Well, the same paper, which
will come out later this year, also
explores well, did the places in East
Africa, which where early humans lived,
where we find fossils and stone tools, do
those also see fluctuations of this sort?
And it turns out that all of the really
prolonged of high climates variability, we
see also amplification in landscape
variability in East African sedimentary
basins. So for example, this place with
the almost unpronounceable name of
Olorgesailie in southern Kenya, where I've
been working for the last 30 years, we see
that between 350,000 and 50,000 years ago,
which was the high to prolonged tide
labeled H2 in the previous diagram, that
time period that we see the landscape
changing in amazing ways of down cutting
of the basin and then the basin filling up
with sediments compared with earlier in
time. And so we think that these are
climate, under climate control, these vast
changes in landscape. And we see this for
all of the other prolonged high
variability itervals. Well, I wondered
whether in this prolonged high variability
intervals, what happened? Was there
anything interesting that happened in
human evolutionary history? And you can
see the time scale of five million years
on the left. And what I've recorded here
are the eight, that is the 25% longest
periods of high climate variability and
the numbers that we've assigned them in
this paper to come out. And we thought,
"Okay, well, what goes on here? What can
we tell from the fossil and archaeological
record?" It turns out that almost
everything that's interesting in African
human evolution is concentrated in those
periods of high climate variability. FAD.
It's a strange word, but it just means
first appearance date where a fossil or an
archaeological piece of evidence shows us
the beginning of a particular lineage and
our evolutionary tree or behavior. And so
for Australopithecus, of all the major
genera in our evolutionary tree,
Australopithecus and homo and
Paranthropus, are concentrated in a period
of high predicted high climate
variability. Also that of homo sapiens at
the top of the chart there. And also the
origin of every single major technological
and behavioral transition in human
evolutionary history is focused in one of
these prolonged high climate variability
intervals. Now one thing that could be
easily criticized about this is that yeah,
but new fossils are found all the time and
there are going to be new finds that are
made. Well, that happened about a month
and a half ago with a fossil jaw from
Ethiopia that repositioned the origin of
the genus homo. Well it turns out that it
repositioned it in the next earliest, in
the oldest period of high climate
variability. Now I'm not saying that this
is proof, but it's nice to see a robust
predictive model about this relationship
of African human evolutionary history and
these periods of high climate variability.
We'see what happens next with the the
discoveries. And so we've also seen in our
evolutionary tree that we used to have the
march of hominids going from ape-like to
human-like, and that gave a sense of
inevitability about the existence of
species on Earth. Well, that idea has been
completely discarded, and we see that we
are part of a much more diverse
evolutionary tree. And in the context of
environmental dynamics, as the conditions
of life change with the shifts in
landscape and in food and water and
shelter, it makes sense that new
behavioral possibilities, new adaptations
and ways of life, were at a premium if
they could allow a greater degree of
adjustment in these time periods of very
strong variability in the environment, but
this also means, this also means, since
we're the last bipeds standing, that other
ways of life, prior means of existence,
could not be sustained, and they were
lost. In the light of environmental
dynamics, we can also inspect this
overview of the adaptive history related
to the origin eventually of homo sapiens,
and we can now see these adaptations as
the evolution of behavioral flexibility
and a wider range, the development of a
wider range of adaptive options and being
able to switch strategies, essentially
adaptability in the face of an unstable
world. I don't have time to go through all
of these points certainly, but we can
point out few of them. So for example,
things like a simple stone flaking and
carrying of food and stones across the
landscape associated with the genus homo,
were ways of being able to buffer the
changing menu of food, food distribution
and food abundance over time during a high
variability interval. The most rapid rate
of increasing brain size relative to body
size. Well, the brain is our organ of
plasticity, one of our organs of
plasticity, and that also becomes more
understandable, not as something that
evolved in a specific narrow set of
environmental and survival conditions, but
in relationship to changing circumstances.
Increased cultural diversity and
technological innovation, not, of course,
as a characteristic of our own species and
as multiplied the options, the behavioral
options within our own species. We also
see in this chart the foundations for a
human altered planet, and for example the
changes in technology, control of fire and
building of shelters, the ...even things
like the moving of complex ...moving of
resources across the landscape. We can see
in the archaeological record, we'll talk
more about that in a moment, and so what
we see is that we have become very good at
surviving by modifying our surroundings,
and that humans, as a result, have spread
worldwide, and so thus we have global
change, global transformation of
landscapes and the consumption of
resources even founded in this early
evolutionary history of human beings. Now
my research team has been working toward
the top of this time tree, about 300,000
years ago and very quickly. These are some
of the things that were occurring in that
period going back to 280,000 years ago,
and remember that's the time period in
Africa of prolonged high climate
variability, and we see the beginning of
innovations. We see increasing innovation,
wider social networks, trade, the
beginning of awareness of groups that are
distant, far away, that you cannot see,
and yet you're able to have a sense of
values, of valuable rock, like obsidian
rock that was traded over long distance,
complex symbolic activity, complex
thinking and planning. And I would see
this overall as, in an environmental
context, that we examine now in Africa, a
greater capacity to adjust to new
environments. I'm not gonna show you any
more than that other than to say that our
research team is about to extend some of
these traits even further back in time
prior to 300,000 years ago. And so what we
then come up with is that the new theme
and story, the new theme and hallmark of
our evolutionary story, is one of
adaptability, increasing adaptability to
endure change in the environment, to
thrive in novel environments, to spread
the new habitats, to respond in new ways
to the surrounding. And these are the
characteristics of the genus homo, and
especially embodied in us, homo sapiens.
Final thoughts, the long-term view of
human evolutionary history, the idea of
the inevitability of our species has been
discarded, it's been, I think,
increasingly replaced by an emphasis on
adaptability when human evolution is
framed within the study of
paleo-environments. And finally,
adaptability, according to the definitions
that I just gave, and the demise of ways
of life, have been two sides of the
evolutionary process, and I think the
question ahead for us, is that this is
evolutionary history, but in the cultural
history that is now unfolding, will that
still be the case? Thank you very much.